Mona Ahmed is a living taboo Allah if I
had another life then I would just pray
to God and ask him to make me either a
complete man or a complete woman and not
a mixture not an in-between his life is
no life
mouna belongs to a group known in India
as hydras or eunuchs Indians consider
hydras to be an entirely separate gender
like most UNIX Nona was born physically
male but in her heart she felt very
different from the soul that is within
me I have always felt like a girl and I
have never considered myself a boy to
find a place in society
Mona embraced her only real option she
joined the eunuchs Mona had her male
sexual organs completely removed she was
physically transformed body hair
vanished her voice changed and she
developed breasts
and for 40 years Mona made her living
the only way a unit can buy singing and
dancing at weddings and births
celebrations
in India more than half a million
eunuchs live on the fringes of society
over time they forge their own families
with values and rules of conduct today
Nonna is going to visit her eunuch
family she's partly supported by her two
disciples Nargis and Sonam we don't have
any child of our own
so these are our children the trio
scouts the streets can be seen for work
and jesting with potential customers
after a bit of searching they hit pay
dirt a young couple has yet to receive
the blessings of the unit they're
believed by many Indians to possess the
power to both bless and curse in killed
Wallace there is power in their blessing
God even prayers to God aren't as
powerful as the blesses of the eunuchs
Sonam attends to the customary blessing
while Nargis and Mona joke with the
family about future children
Mona dreams of the day when Indians see
her is more than just a eunuch but a
complete person I wish everyone would
consider us as humans and not think of
us as a third sex why should we do that
until that day
India's eunuchs will continue as they
have for generations living taboo lives
singing dancing and surviving